all right welcome to the 77th and last
Academy Awards so great night tonight we
have like four black nominees tonight so
cray it's kind of like the death Oscar
jam tonight now remember you are kidding
every movie was incredible every movie
was magic hold it all great then you
grow up and you watch some of those same
movies and you're like Rocky five sucks
now I love the Oscars you know why I
love the Oscars because the Oscars are
the only show the only awards show with
the people getting awards don't perform
that's right there's no acting at the
Oscars
none at all you go to the Grammys then
sing it you go to the Tony Awards they
singing and dancing you go to the source
Awards they sing and dancing and
shooting okay but there's no acting at
the Oscars at all can I get a little
acting just to be or not to be a Morgan
Freeman do a shampoo commercial
something right like the only acting you
ever see at the Oscars and when people
act like they're not mad they lost but I
remember one year when our Halle Berry
won the Oscar Nicole Kidman was smiling
so wide she should have wanted any actor
Oscars for her great performance now
this year in Hollywood some of the most
controversial movies no one wanted to
make man some of the best movies of the
year
nobody wanted to make man you know one
of my favorite movies this year was a
Fahrenheit 9/11 Fahrenheit 9/11 was
beautiful makeup
microphone did not get nominated for an
Oscar okay right now Michael was gone I
should have just made supersize me I've
done the research
hey uh you know a lot of people like the
bass Bush I'm not gonna bass Bush here
tonight I saw Fahrenheit 9/11
I think Bush is a genius I think Bush
did some things this year you nobody in
this room could do nobody in this room
could pull off okay good what's
basically reapplied for his job this
year now can you imagine applying for a
job and while you're applying for that
job as a movie in every theater in the
country that shows how much you suck at
that job it'd be hard to get hired with
it so I watched Fahrenheit I learned
some stuff man and Bush did some things
you could never get away with at your
job bad never ever
you know what Bush got in the office
they had a surplus of money not as like
a 70 trillion dollar deficit now just
imagine who worked at the gap you
closing out your register and his 70th
trillion dollars short the average
person will get in trouble for something
like that right nut bush
No
then Dennis started a law that's cool
support the troops who started a war now
just imagine you worked at the gap
you're 70 trillion behind on your
register and did you start a war with
Banana Republic because you say they got
toxic tank tops over there you have to
war
people are dying a thousand gap
employees are dead
that's right bleeding all over the
khakis you finally take over Banana
Republic and find out they never made
tank tops in the first place see at
least they make movies for white people
to enjoy real movies with plots with
actors not rappers with real names like
like legs you know like so catch me if
you can you know like Saving Private
Ryan black movies don't have real names
you get names like barbershop that's not
a name that's just a location barbershop
cookout car wash they've been making the
same movie for 40 years that's right you
know larger maps coming soon and after
that check cashing place